say you've been going out with somebody  and you're really good friends with them  and you're no longer romantically  interested does that mean friendships  off the table for exes temporarily for  now take a few months to truly get over  them once you're truly over them and you  know that because it's not tugging at  you in that way you want to be friends  it doesn't hurt to be friends go at it  but the majority of people once it gets  there are like that's going to be  complicated we don't i don't need that  friendship friend excuse and i say  excuse because it is an excuse at the  beginning it's just no i can be friends  without actually having my guts ripped  out every time i talk to them and no you  can't not at the beginning